[Musique]
plus de deux entreprises sur 3
rencontres des difficultés de
recrutement et jusqu'à 80 % dans
certains secteurs nous avons identifié
plus de 120 métiers en tension
aujourd'hui alors qu'en 2015 on enchassé
50 pourtant 13% des jeunes ne sont ni en
formation ni en étude ni en emploi très
fort puisqu'on considère que le quart
des petites entreprises connaissent une
baisse de leur chiffre d'affaires et
donc c'est tout à fait significatif on
peut regretter que beaucoup de personnes
soient sans emploi alors même que des
entreprises pourraient les recruter et
donc favoriser leur insertion
professionnelle nous sommes affrontés à
des défis sur les transitions numériques
démographiques environnementale en
particulier et on sait bien que seuls
l'évolution des compétences permettra de
relever ces défis nous voyons trois
leviers principaux d'abord la formation
initiale qui doit participer à mieux
informer les jeunes sur la variété des
métiers et sur les perspectives réelles
de chaque filière ensuite la formation
tout au long de la vie celle des
demandeurs d'emploi pour offrir
davantage de qualifications un meilleur
accompagnement et une prise en compte
des freins périphériques à l'emploi
comme logement le transport la garde
d'enfants mais aussi celle des salariés
tout au long de leur carrière enfin le
levier de l'attractivité grâce aux
atouts que sont la Responsabilité
Sociétale des Entreprises le partage de
la valeur ou les nouveaux modes
d'organisation du travail nous proposons
par exemple d'intégrer au cursus
scolaire un temps spécialement dédié à
la découverte des métiers à la fois en
classe de 5ème mais aussi en seconde
générale le nombre d'apprentis augmente
mais sont financeur France compétence
vit aujourd'hui à crédit il ne faut pas
que cela décourage l'investissement dans
ce mode de formation et enfin nous
faisons également plusieurs
recommandations pour simplifier la
formation continue et surtout mieux
orienter les actions de formation vers
les métiers en tension et les métiers
d'avenir il nous semble aussi que chaque
salarié dev rait pouvoir suivre l'année
de ses 45 ans un bilan de compétences
afin de préparer sa seconde partie de
carrière